we're gonna go over uh Brennan's
specialty the Darth show so let's say
you shoot in with this half ass single
leg that you like to do all right so so
you're sitting here I'm going to give
them the single leg Yeah I'm just gonna
put Brian's little baby bird head down
here and sprawl out here now I'm gonna
shoot this left arm through here yeah
yeah that's not fun I feel like you're
next that's because I gave you the DARS
now I'm not gonna just give you the dog
show me how you get out of it now now
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna pull back
here okay okay okay
now now I've got him here okay he thinks
he's got the DARS now here's what I'm
gonna do go ahead do your thing back I'm
staying right here I'm not going
anywhere okay yeah I'm not going
anywhere and I'm on the phone look hello
hello is there anybody there I'm on the
phone it's about being on the phone oh
what's this what's this a huge arm I can
spin around bang bang boom boom